[Musique]
j'en tire les conclusions en me retirant
pleine vie politique je crois que c'est
à pois de bichari pascoe
salut à tous aujourd'hui on va tenter de
cerner le positionnement politique d'
emmanuel macron lui-même se revendique
d'un nouveau clivage dits progressistes
à la fois de gauche et de droite
les journalistes et autres commentateurs
de la vie publique considère souvent par
défaut qu étant issu d'une majorité de
centre gauche qu'il doit être de ce bord
là ses adversaires politiques eux sont
partagés
ceux de gauche le classent à droite et
ceux de droite le classe à gauche chacun
le plaçant où il veut en fonction de ses
propres intérêts personne ne voulant la
voir dans son camp mais il ya un moyen à
peu près neutre politiquement de savoir
si macro est plus de gauche ou de droite
c'est de regarder le profil de ce que
son discours attire et il se trouve que
le cevipof le centre d'étude de la vie
politique française
rattaché à sciences po a produit une
étude sur les électeurs potentiels de
maquereaux je vous propose dans un
premier temps de voir ce que dit cette
étude
cette étude a été réalisée par jérôme
jaffré en septembre octobre 2016 ça fait
quelques mois maintenant mais c'est la
seule du genre que l'on aime voici les
résultats
comment se lissent camelot par exemple
pour la question faut-il augmenter le
temps de travail mais 7% des électeurs
de hollande 45 % des électeurs du lac
rond et 52% des électeurs de juppé
répondre oui autre exemple faut-il
diminuer les aides sociales
25% des électeurs de hollande 53 % des
électeurs du lac rond et 56% des
électeurs de juppé a répondu oui dernier
exemple 25% des électeurs de hollande 52
% des électeurs de macron et 60% des
électeurs de juppé pense qu'il ya trop
d'immigrés en france
je ne vais pas détailler tout le tableau
vous pouvez mettre pause si ça vous
intéresse
globalement on s'aperçoit que les
électeurs d'une accro sont très à droite
et leur profil de réponse s'approche
plus de celui des électeurs de juppé que
de ceux de hollande
autre élément intéressant l'étude s'est
aussi intéressé aux électeurs potentiels
de françois bayrou
et là surprise ceux ci sont globalement
plus à gauche que les électeurs de
macron et y compris sur des questions
identitaires qui sont pourtant marqué à
droite
ensuite l'étude s'est intéressée aux
seuls électeurs mac rognan on y apprend
que ceux-ci se répartissent
équitablement en trois catégories ceux
qui se sentent des gauches ceux qui se
sentent de droite et ceux qui n'ont pas
d'affinités partisane comme précédemment
on a posé des questions économiques et
identitaires à ces trois catégories
voici les résultats si on les compare à
ceux des électeurs potentiels de
françois hollande on voit que la gauche
macro n'y n est plus à droite que la
gauche hollandaise normal il constitue
l'ailé droite du centre gauche
plus intéressant quand on compare ces
résultats à ceux des électeurs de juppé
surprise les électeurs de juppé sont
moins à droite que ceux de macron se
déclarant de droite
étonnant pour un candidat centriste
deuxième surprise quand on compare les
résultats aux électeurs de bayrou on
s'aperçoit que les électeurs sans
référence partisane de macron sont aussi
plus à droite que les électeurs de
bayrou
en clair la cre ont constitué volontiers
au centre gauche a une majorité
d'électeurs qui sont plus à droite que
ce bayrou censé pourtant être de
centre-droit pour faire clair électorat
de macron t majoritairement de droite et
surtout de droite qui s'ignore vous
allez peut-être me dire normal qu'il
attire des gens qui sont de fait centre
droit c'est un libéral intégral à la
fois sur les questions économiques et
sociétales ce qui est caractéristique de
cette partie
et politique en france alors oui c'est
vrai mais ce n'est pas suffisant pour
expliquer son succès mais comprendre
totalement sa ligne politique
car après tout des candidats libéraux
intégraux de centre droit il y en a eu à
la primaire de la droite et du centre
nathalie kosciusko morizet et bruno le
maire et ils ont tous les deux fait des
scores ridicules alors comment se
fait-il que macro lui a réussi à
cristalliser cet électorat quant à eux
n'y sont pas arrivés à mon avis pour
comprendre ce paradoxe 1 il faut
s'intéresser aux discours macro mien ses
adversaires disent que c'est un discours
bidon ou crevant confino télévangélisme
pourtant macron porte un discours bien
plus idéologique qu'on veut bien le dire
et ça se comprend si on se rappelle de
son parcours il a fait l'ena la plus
grande école de management et gestion
publique et a été banquier d'affaires ce
monde du haut management public et privé
véhicule un discours managérial et
gestionnaires qui est très en phase avec
le système économique actuel
eh bien à mon avis macro qui a été
façonné par ce discours managérial et
gestionnaire est une transposition de
celui ci en politique
et si on adopte cette grille de lecture
son discours prend du sens d'abord
mettons nous d'accord sur ce que
j'appelle discours managérial
si vous avez travaillé dans une
entreprise un peu conséquente
numériquement vous avez fatalement été
confrontés vous savez ces discours très
nerveux dans le but est de pacifier
l'entreprise de la soudée derrière sa
direction en créant une unité des
valeurs et une histoire artificielle
très aseptisé
c'est un monde où les ouvriers
deviennent des opérateurs les employés
des collaborateurs ou des équipiers les
chefs de bureaux d air plus sain ce
monde ou joyeux nous marchons tous dans
la même direction pour le bien de
l'entreprise qui est avant tout une
grande aventure humaine
initié par le fondateur visionnaire dans
laquelle il faut penser satisfaction
client avec une volonté de démarche
qualité le tout en trouvant des
solutions clients innovantes et
impactante pour répondre aux impératifs
du marché valider notre business model
et viabilisé nos centres de profit
bref c'est le monde des femmes une
culture d'entreprise et d'esprit
corporate un monde politiquement neutre
fait de bons sentiments
porté par un discours envoûtant bien
qu'assez creux qui en fait en europe des
préoccupations avant tout économique
alors concrètement que donne ce discours
chez makro
tout d'abord il ya la création d'un
récit mythique et pacifié autour de
l'histoire de la france dans ce récit
chacun chaque collaborateur de
l'entreprise france a apporté sa pierre
à l'édifice il n'ya pas d'opinion
politique
pas d'opposition chacun contribue à la
marche vers le progrès et ceux qui te
raconter n'importe quoi au niveau
historique
par exemple sur l' affaire dreyfus
lorsque notre pays a dû se battre pour
l'honneur d'un capitaine parce qu'il
était juif mais parce qu'en même temps
c'était l'honneur de la république dont
il était question non le pays ne s'est
pas battu pour dreyfus c'est surtout le
nom de la gauche de l'avoir défendu
quand la droite elle était largement
anti dreyfusards d'heure on a également
une belle réécriture de l'histoire sur
la laïcité
lorsque les progressistes ont voulu
mener le combat pour la liberté de
conscience et pour la laïcité pour voter
cette belle loi de 1905 séparant
l'église de l'état il a fallu des femmes
et des hommes de gauche et de droite
déjà des femmes députées de gauche comme
de droite qui ont voté la laïcité en
y'a pas du bien avoir des masses et
c'est oublier un peu vite qu'une bonne
partie de la droite catholique après un
scandale contre cette loi un dernier
exemple sur l'avortement
lorsqu'il a fallu le courage de simone
veil de jacques chirac et de valéry
giscard d'estaing pour porter ce projet
pour porter cette réforme de l'ibg il a
fallu une majorité de droite et de
gauche pour pouvoir la beauté comme si à
un moment donné toute la société
française
naturellement s'était dit tiens ce
serait bien qu'on légalise l'avortement
alors qu'en fait ça faisait des
décennies que les femmes à avorter
clandestinement et que les mouvements
progressistes se battait pour sa
légalisation
ensuite pour fédérer macron affiche les
valeurs corporate de l'entreprise france
il se contente de reprendre des lieux
communs et exhibe des valeurs qu'elle
nous sommes tous censés adhérer puisque
inculqué depuis l'enfance liberté
égalité fraternité
son discours est articulé autour de la
devise républicaine et encore la
démocratie est souvent considérée comme
une tension entre l'égalité et la
liberté entre des valeurs de gauche et
de droite et macron met en avant la
fraternité la moins politique d'être en
est à l'écouté
cette fraternité fait tout y compris le
café si nous sommes écologistes c'est
par fraternité avec nos semblables
là pour le coup on est en plein neuf
langues managériale écologie par la
fraternité ça ne veut rien dire on
pourrait même prendre la phrase à
l'envers la fraternité par l'écologie on
aurait le même résultat
c'est d'ailleurs une autre
caractéristique du discours d'entreprise
repris par macro au réemploi le
détournement de concept jugé
positivement qui sont dans l'air du
temps
par exemple dans le monde de
l'entreprise on a le greenwashing qui
consiste à vous faire passer un truc
pour écolo alors qu'il ne l'est pas du
tout là avec macro on à l'égalité ou
chimie on ne pourrait que protéger
certains contre le risque du chômage
parce qu'il va toucher peut-être toutes
et tous des commerçants des artisans des
paysans des entrepreneurs la vraie
égalité des chances c'est de permettre
que chacune et chacun est une garantie
puissent accéder à une indemnité quand
ils se trouvent au chômage
quelle que soit sa condition
[Applaudissements]
l'égalité des chances ternes positifs
dans notre pays ce serait donc d'avoir
une assurance chômage pour tous les
statuts là on est quand même un peu dans
le détournement de concept à côté de
tout ça le discours mac rognant est
aussi gestionnaire
si on regarde de près la majeure partie
du discours c'est du lyrisme la
falsification historique du détournement
de concepts et parfois de la licence
poétique de me dire et le roi arthur
c'est à dire qu'il ya des moments ça
fait classe et ça ne l'a peu près rien
dire
le seul domaine où l'on repère un fil
conducteur c'est l'économique avec
quelques propositions disséminées ici ou
là sans le discours d'entreprise kg tour
s'est gentiment libéral mais à force
d'être disséminés dans le discours un
peu d'économies avec l'égalité
d'économies avec la fraternité ce qui
devrait être le coeur du discours mac
revient à ceux plus ou moins inaperçu
maintenant qu'on a vu le discours mac
revient il est temps de se poser une
question encore un discours inspiré du
management et la gestion qui a cours
dans le monde du salariat pose-t-il
problème en politique
tout d'abord la vision progressiste de
macron est une forme de négation du
programme en le réduisant à un aspect
purement législatif tout le monde à
voter pour tel loi on passe sous silence
et dizaine d'années qui se sont souvent
écoulé entre le début d'une lutte
généralement menées par la gauche et sa
traduction dans la loi par la gauche et
une partie de la droite et qui n'est
souvent en fin de compte une
reconnaissance des changements de moeurs
produite par ce but
ensuite dans une république avoir comme
seule orientation politique claire et
valeur de celle-ci n'a aucun sens le
politique est censé se construire sur
ces valeurs près politique ajuste les
rappeler sinon ça donne un discours qui
ne différant rien d'une campagne de
promotion du civisme est financé par
l'état
liberté égalité fraternité et bien la
fraternité de la république c'est la
même chose on fait tous partie de la
même famille on est la france ce qui en
découle c'est que le discours macro n'y
en avait il pas de valeur propre juste
quelques propositions économiques
c'était un discours politique à
proprement parler c'est un discours sans
anthropologie spécifique c'est-à-dire
sans vision de l'humain normalement
quand vous avez un discours vous avez le
programme et la vision de l'humanité qui
vont avec
par exemple pour la droite il ya des
hiérarchies naturel dans la société pour
la gauche les mégalithes et souterrains
dit câble et l'humain est perfectible si
on améliore ses conditions de vie on
peut déduire le discours du programme et
vice versa là on ne peut pas déduire
d'orientation politique à partir de ce
discours à part sur l'économie qui est
la grosse exception mais passe inaperçu
au milieu des licences poétique résultat
chez makro le discours et le programme
sont presque complètement déconnecté
derrière la liberté l'égalité la
fraternité
on met le programme politique qu'on veut
la crau et vêtements libéral mais à peu
de choses près sans les quelques
sous-entendus économique
il pourrait tout aussi bien proposer un
programme communiste avec le même
discours le discours managérial et
gestionnaire est avant tout un discours
qui visait à la performance économique
en nous demandant d' adhérer à des
valeurs fédératrices autour d'une entité
commune et ne demande pas notre avis sur
l'orientation de l'entreprise parce que
ce n'est pas aux employés de déterminer
la stratégie de la boîte
là on a la même chose on fait deja bon
compte sur le doute et république mais
on ne nous demande pas notre avis sur
l'orientation politique sur le programme
qui sera mis en oeuvre on ne fait plus
réellement de politique puisque on a
nous demande plus de nous prononcer sur
la marge future de la société
cette disjonction entre le discours et
le programme est une véritable négation
du fait politique est le seul qui
décidera au final dans la société macro
nien ce sera le cap man
alors eh bien voilà même s'il ne s'agit
plus d'interprétations personnelles
j'espère que cette vidéo vous aura
permis d'appréhender un peu mieux le
discours de macron si cette vidéo vous a
plu je vous invite à la partager
il se pourrait également faire d'autres
vidéos complémentaires sur mac rond dans
tous les cas je vous donne rendez-vous
pour une prochaine émission
d'ici là je vous dis portez vous bien et
à la prochaine
[Musique]